I know you're out there it looks rather
gray but calm right now but tell us
about the timetable how's it gonna look
behind you in the next few hours oh yeah
but you're absolutely right it is calm
right now and that's a good thing we
want people to take advantage of this
time that they have in the New York City
area it's up until about afternoon and
then what I'm concerned about is that
people who treated this like a normal
day
we need to stagger getting people out of
here so don't get a lot of people on the
roads overnight tonight that winds gonna
crank up the snow storms moving to the
coast line and once it gets to the coast
it has all the fuel it's got the jet
stream to pump it up it's got plenty of
available moisture
you've got the Atlantic we have all the
makings of a major snow storm a blizzard
and there are blizzard warnings out but
there's actually hurricane-force wind
warnings out and that's for the eastern
end of Long Island also toward the Cape
we're gonna have seventy mile an hour
winds with two to three feet of blowing
snow this is going to be a horrible
situation and one of the things that I
want people to think about is just
consider the worst here let's say that
there are going to be power outages
let's just think that it's going to be
you make sure that you have the food
that your family needs to get through
these next couple of days right because
if the power goes down in your community
they're not going to get it back for a
while so we're just trying to today get
people ready this is up and down the
coastline overnight tonight just say it
yeah you know given that we've gone
through hurricane sandy and Irene and
others or you know we are I've got my
power generator up ok so absolutely tell
us where it's gonna be just very quickly
Sam where is it gonna be the worst I
gotta say it's we're right on the edge
of New York in the city the island
anyplace remember this is a coastal
storm so the closer you are to the
center of this storm the worse the
conditions are New York is right on the
edge and we could waffle a little bit on
those snow totals we're watching it
moment by moment when it develops
overnight tonight so right now we're at
that 12 to 18 area and it really can
fall in that zone eastern end of Long
Island getting much more could be 36
inches of snow also up toward Boston the
same thing one of the things you're
going to notice is we're going to
tighten those snow bands once we have
this low developed it's about a 50-mile
path of who gets what
thank you so much for joining us and of
course stay warm and stay safe as well
Sam champion weather comm meteorologist
on the impending snowstorm the blizzard
of historic proportions it's going to
hit the Northeast